[Music]
welcome back America we're talking with
Senator Ted Cruz his brand new Fantastic
book unwoke how to defeat cultural
Marxism in America very pre covers all
really that's going on in this country
today so my question is does this
Administration actually demonstrate in
its own actions Even in our own country
concern about
citizens the exact opposite they're
interested in power power and ideology
and that's consistent with cultural
Marxism is about using culture to
enforce through force and power their
Orthodoxy when when it comes to you
asked about the
Border what is happening at the southern
border is is a catastrophe that has no
precedent in the history of our nation I
was down at the southern border I went
out on midnight Patrol with the border
patrol agents as always within about an
hour you encounter illegal immigrants it
takes almost no no time at all we
encountered a group of 20 to 25 mostly
women and children there was a
13-year-old girl she was unaccompanied
had no family member with her there was
a 15-year-old boy he was unaccompanied
no family members with her there was a
16-year-old girl she was unaccompanied
they all said they were going to see
their teos Teo Spanish for Uncle now
when we ask them does your tio know
you're coming no no I just have a number
I'm supposed to call him it was obvious
these teos didn't
exist that these kids were being brought
in and were being trafficked what was
most haunting there was a little girl a
10-year-old
girl who said she was traveling with her
father and her father was a man who was
like 35 or
40 who was not her father he had his arm
around her but it was not a gentle
caress it was it was almost like a
headlock he was holding her still and
forcefully the little girl was terrible
ified we asked about her mother she just
looked at at the man she was with what
are we supposed to say on this it was
horrifying you know during the Trump
Administration they would DNA test when
a child arrived with an adult man and
they claimed to be father and and child
they DNA test of about 30% of them it
was a lie about 30% had no biological
relationship whatsoever Joe Biden came
in and ended the DNA testing they don't
want to know and the cartel are
literally renting
children now you ask do they care are
they compassionate no I look I was
looking at these kids and I was
physically sick mark because I was
looking at teenagers I have a
13-year-old daughter I was actually
standing there was just past midnight it
was the morning of my daughter's 13th
birthday and I was looking at that
13-year-old girl and thinking my God you
were about to you're going to be trapped
in sex slavery and the board of Patrol
agents can't do anything about
it because Joe Biden and KLA Harris and
Alejandra mayorcas don't want them to do
anything about it it's
evil like the the the argument that the
Democrats are compassionate on
immigration is insane and then when you
overlay the war in Israel the risk of a
terror attack today in the United States
of America is greater than it has been
any day since
9/11 and you mention
the people that have been apprehended on
the terror watch list and more people
were apprehended on the terror watch
list than the previous decade combined
just last year but you know that's not
the number that worries me the number
that worries me is 2
million we've had 8 million people cross
illegally under Joe Biden two million of
those are what are called Goda ways so 6
million of them the majority of them
were like this group we encountered that
night they go they look for the border
of Patrol agents they turn themselves in
the 2 million Goda ways are people that
they spot that they identify okay we see
them but they get away the Goda ways are
much more likely to be criminals to be
murderers to be rapists to be child
molesters to be gang members to be MS13
or to be terrorists just a couple of
weeks ago the San Diego Office of the
Customs and Border Patrol put out a
written memo saying be on guard for
Hamas and Hezbollah
terrorists crossing our Southern border
who will pretend not to be from Hamas
and Hezbollah and if you're a
terrorist you're not going to turn
yourself into the border of Patrol
you're going to be one of the 2 million
gotway and you know just a week ago the
head of the FBI was testifying in the
house and he said he was concerned about
the risk of Hamas carrying out a terror
attack here I got to admit that scares
the hell out of me why because the FBI
and I talk about it in the book on woke
the weaponization of the Department of
Justice and the FBI the FBI and doj have
been saying for 3 years the greatest
risk of violence in America is homegrown
terrorism and white white
supremacists Now give me a break look
Nazis and clansmen are idiots they're
bigots they're morons they're imbeciles
and they're e unequivocally evil but
it's not like we're seeing a r Rising
surge of Nazis and clansmen across the
country this is is made up in the fever
dreams of the
left and they utterly ignore Global
jihadists that have declared a mission
of murdering Americans and the fact that
the head of the FBI Chris Ray who both
you and I
know suddenly said to the house there's
a real risk of amas carrying out a
terror attack here it made me think holy
cow what does he know now that we don't
know because something has changed
because 3 weeks ago he wasn't willing to
say that publicly and now he is and and
that has me very worried that that that
they have information that an attack
could be
imminent and on this point when we come
back the
commander-in-chief the president of the
United States doesn't even discuss it
nope doesn't even think about it the
commander-in-chief the president of the
United States says he's concerned about
hostages Americans except when they're
in Afghanistan we have hundreds of
people over there we don't what happened
to them that's as a result of his
conduct you never hear about them again
he pays $6 billion I'm not going to
engage in idiot talk about whether that
means that Iran gets it or not Iran
wanted it and got it that's the bottom
line just weeks before what took place
with Hamas so he increases the
price and the motivation for hostages
yep and now he's blaming Israel needs to
back off so he can get him out now Hamas
wants money don't forget unwoke how to
defeat culture Marxism in America this
is a big time book ladies and gentlemen
I predict it's going to be one of the
big books of the year you ought to grab
your copy this is the first exclusive
interview you can get it on amazon.com
right now and any major bookstore
starting on Tuesday hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else